Press Secretary Kaili McEnany held her second
press briefing yesterday.
You might remember that Donald Trump's previous
secretary, press secretary Stephanie Grissom,
held zero point zero press conferences, press
briefings during her entire time as press
secretary.
Kelly McCann and he did one of I believe it
was Friday and she did one yesterday.
Now, in her first one, she famously pledged
not to lie to the press.
Then she told four major lies, too, related
to the Russia investigation.
One related to ventilators and one related
to Michael Flynn.
So in about three minutes, she broke her pledge
not to lie.
Yesterday, 12 seconds into the press briefing,
she lied by claiming that the U.S. is doing
the most testing merely by saying we've done
7 million tests.
Of course, as you all know, what matters is
per capita in a country of three hundred and
thirty one million people.
Now, the last time that we covered her press
briefings, I pointed out the press corps needs
to ask her about that time.
She went on Fox News in February and said
Trump will never allow Corona virus to come
to the United States.
Here's what she said back in February.
Absolutely.
This president will always put America first.
He will always protect American citizens.
We will not see diseases like the Corona virus
come here.
We will not see terrorism come here.
Isn't that refreshing when contrasting it
with the awful presidency of President Obama?
Kelly McCann, thank you so much.
Good to see you.
Thank you.
Now to his credit.
Jeff Mason from Reuters yesterday asked her
about exactly those comments.
Here is how she handled it.
She turned to a particular page in her notebook.
She knew the question might show up.
She was prepared.
Here's how she addressed it.
She worked for the campaign and he made a
comment, I believe, on Fox.
She said President Trump will not allow the
corona virus to come to this country, given
what has happened since then, obviously.
Would you like to take that back?
Well, first, let me note, I was asked a question
on Fox Business about president's travel restrictions.
I noted.
What was the intent behind those travel restrictions,
which is we will not see the Corona virus
come here.
We will not see terrorism come here, referring
to an earlier set of travel restrictions.
I guess I would turn the question back on
the media and ask similar questions.
Does Fox want to take back that they proclaim
that the Corona virus would not be a deadly
pandemic.
Does The Washington Post want to take back
that they told Americans to get a grip?
The flu is bigger than the Corona virus, says
The Washington Post.
Likewise want to take back that our brains
are causing us to exaggerate the threats of
the Corona virus.
Does New York Times want to take back that
fear of the virus, maybe spreading it, spreading
faster than the virus itself?
Does NPR want to take back that the flu was
a much bigger threat than the Corona virus?
And finally, once again, The Washington Post.
Would they like to take back that the governments
should not respond aggressively to the Corona
virus?
I'll leave you with those questions and maybe
you'll have some answers in a few days, not
just your about your.
What's so funny about this is that she clearly
feels like that was a huge mike drop moment
where she walks off after turning it back
around on the press.
It's actually cringeworthy and the entire
thing was cringe worthy.
She may not last long because it's it's getting
more and more embarrassing.
Now, the trumpets seem to be liking it.
That's what might keep her in the job.
She starts the briefing 35 minutes late.
It lasts only 25 minutes total after taking
only a few questions.
She abruptly walks off after being asked about
a completely laughable, ridiculous thing that
she said.
But the Trump is love it.
Donald Trump, Don Junior, tweeted yesterday,
saying her answer was fire.
And a whole bunch of Trump ists are just thrilled
with Kaylie Malkin.
So let's analyze her argument.
She said Trump won't let Corona virus come
to the United States.
And she responds by saying, listen, a lot
of media outlets said this is not going to
be a big deal in the United States.
That's a terrible argument, number one.
It's not really an argument.
It's actually the two quick way.
The fallacy, which is the appeal to hypocrisy,
is another way to say it, which is when you
tried to discredit your opponent's argument
about something you did by pointing out that
someone else did the same.
Thing and it's it's fallacious.
Strictly speaking, how can the media criticize
her when they said similar things supposedly
is the way the argument goes.
Now, first of all, when the media was saying
this may not be a big deal in the United States,
the media was reporting what different medical
experts were saying.
Many of whom were people that were involved
with the Trump administration.
And so so one thing to understand is a lot
of the articles she's quoting are articles
that are essentially citing the medical experts
that the Trump administration picked for,
say, things about coronavirus.
That's number one.
It's not like the media reports.
When you look at independent and foreign experts
were not saying this would be a big deal.
In fact, you can look at January and February
and find a whole bunch of media reports that
are not based on what Trump affiliated medical
experts were saying.
If you look at foreign countries, if you look
at independent agencies in the U.S., they
were saying we could take actions that would
prevent this.
But if we don't, it's going to be a disaster.
So she's she's actually wrong about that.
And a lot of the reports that she cites were
simply saying, here's what someone associated
with the administration says is going to happen.
She didn't say.
Here's what an expert says.
She simply said Trump won't allow the virus
to come here.
So she made a very different type of claim
when she went on Fox News and said Obama's
presidency was awful.
Trump's not going to allow it to come here.
That was not.
These are the medical experts alleging that.
Now, secondly, none of those media people
who were simply reporting what was being said
were hired to be Trump's press secretary.
Right.
The question about her competence is a very
valid and good question, because she was hired
to be Trump's press secretary, some vox writer
who quoted a health expert who may have been
wrong or may have been taken out or whatever.
They are not now speaking for the president.
But clearly what she has done is show her
hand.
She is very much willing to attack the media.
She is prepared to attack the media whenever
she gets the questions she doesn't like very
much like Donald Trump does.
That's what we've done.
Make sure you're following The David Pakman
Show on Instagram at David Pakman show.
We'll be back very soon.
The David Pakman Show.
David Pakman dot.com.